[Music]
Aisha welcome to Stanford GSB thank you
for having me I can't believe I'm
sitting here I'm not sure what you think
you're all going to be hearing but I'll
try my
best our view from the top theme this
year is redefining tomorrow and we could
not think of a more fitting guest than
the CEO of zukes a company that's
reimagining Transportation how we move
in this world and so thank you for being
here my pleasure thank you for having me
uh I'm blessed um and really privileged
to be working in this space we have a
lot to get to today so let's dive in I
want to start at the very beginning um
you have a really unique upbringing you
grew up both in senagal and in France
and started traveling back and forth
between the two from a very young age
how did these diverse experiences
influence you well several things first
of all there is an element of luck uh I
I really thank uh my parents um my dad
uh for being in the telecommunication
space and uh seeing from a very
beginning what technology could do
because believe it or not those
companies back then were laying cable
under under the ocean and connecting the
world and then uh but also seeing
differences uh you're in Paris and uh
you see what's possible and then you're
in Sagal and you see what's less
possible back then at least and
Technology played a major part in that
and then my mom uh for reminding me that
even though uh I like to think with
things I like math I love philosophy uh
there's a reason some of the best Phil
or most known uh philosophers are
mathematicians so at least that's my
story and I'm sticking to it um she
reminded me it's all about people
technology is in service of people and
it's also developed by people so you
also need to learn about people and what
makes them tick and how do you get
things done and how do you seek to
understand now the
the interesting thing with my dad is
from a very young age he uh he pushed me
uh towards stem uh and uh he wanted me
to be an engineer which I became but I
think from a social standpoint he had
different
expectations uh he wanted me to
essentially compartmentalize like being
super uh sort of critical in my thinking
and my reasoning but except when it
comes to the social aspect of things
right you Mar a sagales guy he's going
to tell you what to do and you be a good
girl and that's not what ended up
happening uh what ended up happening is
that uh it also shapes just how you live
your life in general and uh around um uh
right after the baloria we started
having a falling out a little bit
because he wanted that little girl that
he wanted and she was gone and she saw
everything through the lands of
engineering and technology which is in a
way how I ended up uh in the US uh to
get away but in a loving way uh from him
uh and that took a little bit of
negotiation but we finally got there uh
except that uh I didn't realize School
in the US was so expensive so you kind
of needed to uh agree with him on some
things yeah and and one of the things uh
we agreed upon was that I would go to DC
because he felt that uh what he failed
uh at doing while I was in
France uh he was going to correct by me
being in DC and around uh the the World
Bank and IMF are in DC and there are a
lot of uh he had a lot of friends and he
felt that they would uh keep me in line
basically uh but it didn't quite work
out because I met this American
Boy and ended up getting married and
we're still married and we have two kids
together that is beautiful and then the
rest is history the rest is history to
to he he passed away uh during covid
actually uh but I do we did make peace I
mean he he's he's proud of me me I know
he's up there smiling at this point I
know he is very proud of you and I know
he was very influential in in that
decision to moving over to to George
Washington University um and studying
Computer Engineering there and after
studying Computer Engineering you then
started your career as a full-time
engineer first in Austin Texas and then
later taking several roles um in the Bay
Area um and then Intel would it be okay
if we go there of course let's go so I
know once you got to Intel you very
quickly Rose the ranks of management up
to Chief strategy
officer that's a lot I want to learn
what did you learn about yourself and
about leadership in that
time couple things first of all the good
jobs are already
taken don't go after the good jobs
they're not available and so look for um
I entered Intel and intel was doing Wild
Max uh by that time um I had uh sort of
Built My Career around Wireless uh it's
I for us Wireless technologist the fact
that you're all sitting here and there's
an unimaginable number of bits that are
moving around as we speak and are all
you're all getting your right data your
right call your right messages uh
believe me uh some 20 years ago we were
dreaming of this moment but we weren't
sure we were going to be able to make it
happen and so I had already t Ed what I
call transformation what I what I call
working on technology that directly
affects hundreds of millions and
billions of people so I go into Intel
because um I happened to live in
Portland Oregon back then intel was
looking at doing stuff in the wiress
space VI ymax which is why I was hired
but when I went in I was like
H I don't think this is going to
work and but it's hard right you enter a
corporation I mean there are brilliant
people around you and you're like it's
not possible that they I mean
something's not right here and so how I
Rose through management and this is this
is connecting to don't take the good
jobs uh was I started asking questions
about what exactly I are we doing and
why are we doing it because I I I really
have some concerns about this and
whether it can work and that ex that
basically led to me uh getting in front
of Shan Maloney daddy permut basically
the top of Intel saying we hear we hear
you asking questions I'm like yeah I'm
asking questions now you also don't go
in there and say well I think your
technology is bad and you're
confused that doesn't work very well
right and so I started saying look I I
think the technology can work but from
an ecosystem standpoint and relative to
3gpp it's a really tough Hill to climb
so let's spark the technology and tell
me what you're trying to do and why
because then we can maybe back up the
boat and talk about is there a different
more effective way to accomplish that
goal so asking a lot of questions not
shying away from uh what I call the
problematic problematic areas uh knowing
myself well I am not a steadystate
person if you have a great business
that's running well and doing well keep
it as far away from me as you can I'll
mess with it I like to Tinker I like to
go on the Ed edes I like to transform I
like to understand why I like to to
dream and so that's basically what
happened then um I had to rely on my
mom's advice which is if you're asking
questions and you're making people
uncomfortable find a way to make them
comfortable and then um daddy was like
yeah you talk a good game and you're
making a lot of sense but can you
actually execute I said I think so and
uh he said well we have an issue with uh
with Wi-Fi
uh would you consider uh he he and raviv
memed would you consider um taking on
the that team maybe yes well the team is
in Israel and I'm I'm four months
pregnant right and I'm like Israel like
and I will never forget raviv mamed goes
yeah we deliver babies in Israel that's
not a problem what and so I ended up
moving to Israel and that's where I
really uh was in a totally different
environment with a brand new team who
was like why are you here like couldn't
they find somebody else and uh but I was
like well I'm here because something's
wrong and uh I'm not doing Alia so
meaning like you know I'm not going to
live in Israel the whole my whole life
and so tell me what's wrong we fix it
and I'm out of your hair and uh that's
where really I had to learn to lead
people I had to learn success I had to
learn failure and I'm naming both
because how you handle both is very
different with success it's very
important to remember that that you
don't have a god-given right to it uh
it's important to remain humble it's
important to continue pushing yourself
and with failure it's important to be
like okay I didn't get here by mistake
so what exactly happened was it the
wrong timing was it the wrong assumption
did I make a mistake uh uh bottle the
trigger so that next time you're in the
same situation you can recognize it and
do something about it but yeah that was
basically the journey yeah it sounds
like there was a lot of self-awareness
that was involved as you thought about
both your career progression and also
managing and coaching others
well I just said you should be humble so
I should be humble too it's a it's a
it's a journey of Discovery around
self-awareness it wasn't always easy and
uh I was super super lucky uh one of the
things that Intel did was um uh it's
very difficult for me to be several
personalities I mean that's just a lot
of energy I just want to be the same
person all the time because otherwise
it's hard to remember like the facial
expression what do I say to whom I'm too
lazy for that and so uh intel was like
well you know you you have a lot of
potential you're doing well uh you we're
even sending you out there but you know
you you need a little bit of Polish like
lovely we're going to get you a coach
okay so I was like oh gosh so the first
few coaches they sent me um the good
news is they let you interview the coach
to see if there's a connection and the
first few well it didn't go very well
cuz they start with you know what's your
Five-Year Plan I actually don't have one
if I'm alive and happy that's a good
start um well you know you why aren't
you saying you want to be a CEO I I'm
not saying I want or don't want that's
not what I'm focused on so it was just
like and I felt like what about you
learn me and then we go from there So
eventually somebody in HR who knew
Marshall Goldsmith uh said uh oh I think
he would be the right coach for you I
Googled him I was like like he's got
bigger fish to fry than me uh but we met
and uh fell in work love with each other
and he pushes me on the Journey of
self-discovery in what way what does
that look like so I had a decision a
very difficult decision to make at least
in my head uh some years ago uh I was
hesitating between staying at Intel and
going to do something else it was at a
very difficult time uh Lots was going on
and uh I was really having trouble
making that decision I was driving my
husband crazy it was just I was probably
driving Intel crazy and so uh Marshall
we were talking about it doing the pros
and cons and I'm just whining and making
it sound like all about he calls it all
about me me me me me and uh so he calls
me up and he's like do you have a mirror
a big mirror at your house I'm like yeah
actually I'm standing in front of one
she's like go in front of the mirror so
I go in front of the mirror he's like
repeat after me I'm like yes life is
good I said yes life is good good in the
grand scheme of things I'm lucky in the
grand schem of things I'm lucky there
are no bad choices here there are no bad
choices here make a choice stick with it
and move make a choice stick with it and
move okay let me know when you've done
that then we can talk about the choice
you've made and how do we make that work
that's sort of like uh you know or he
makes me sometimes I'm just like he's
like get out of your own head like move
on so he's very loving uh very St but he
he does not allow you to hide from
yourself wow at the GSB we actually
place a lot of value on Executive
coaching some of us have coaches others
are taught to coach what advice as you
think about the role Executive coaching
has played in your life what advice do
you have for us as GSB students as we
think about how it could play in our
development look my assumption is that
uh just from a probability and statistic
standpoint you're all going to be
successful and I I'm pleased asking you
to trust trust that and to remember that
stop panicking about it and driving
yourself crazy about it just put it one
foot in front of the other and go
do my biggest advice is because you're
going to be successful it gets
lonely it gets
confusing it gets scary there's a little
Aisha at night she talks to you and
sometime she talks to me and sometimes
you know she's not easy to deal with and
so find somebody who you can have
intimacy with find some somebody who
when they talk to you whether you agree
or disagree is not even the issue you
will
hear you will listen find somebody who
you feel
comfortable talking about the worst part
of yourself
with because that intimacy is really
what is going to help you and the coach
go after what matters to you otherwise
you're just getting a consultant
and that's not really going to lead to
the
greatest achieving the greatest
potential
possible well and I know Marshall is
someone who continues to work with you
today he has been very powerful in
coming along your career journey and so
I actually want to transition and talk
about your next move which was zuk's so
as you were leaving Intel you had
options there were several companies
showing interest in you and you also had
very specific criteria for what you want
out of your next role so tell us why zuk
so first I have to go back to the that
uh that other moment um I disappointed a
lot of people in making the decision
that I made uh and you know guilt and
regret is something you need to learn to
handle and I it stayed with me uh now I
made other people also very happy to be
fair and uh I sort of had a one-on-one
with myself I said okay what just
happened here uh and uh what conclusions
do we draw and one conclusion that I
basically I was like I don't think I'm
going to go to another big
company at the end of the day they are
about all the same they the script
there's a script there are players
agendas I mean it's so I was like I I
just don't want to do that anymore um I
uh and then I that led to well then what
do I want to do and uh uh one of my good
friend in uh the executive recruiting uh
space said well have you written it down
and then I said Marshall they're asking
me he's like yeah I think that's a good
idea because let's not go through that
drama again yeah I said okay fair and so
uh first thing is I wanted to stay in
the Bay Area uh because at that point I
had moved my kids a lot and it took me a
while to understand that even when
you're moving neighborhoods your kids
count that as a move like if the soccer
team changes or if the friends change uh
that's a move to them and they had like
tabulated all the moves and they were
done and they were teenagers and I I
owed them that that was thing one uh
thing two I did not want to uh go to the
public sector or to a public company
because I I can't keep my mouth shut and
so and so I knew if I went to a public
company it's back to investor calls and
go talk to this press and go to this big
event and buy a lot of expensive outfits
for the event and I was just like I I
want these next four to six years for my
kids to be very to be about them and to
not you know I just wanted that privacy
and that
intimacy uh then I was like okay if I'm
going to a private company uh I am not a
Founder but I'm also not a classic
corporate executive I'm like that in
between and so I was like I don't want
to go to a private company where the
founders are being told they need
somebody like me I want to go to a
private company where the founders have
decided that they want somebody like
meh then I wanted to be impactful
technology I mean nothing against you
know this app or this thing but that's
just not I wanted to do something that
was as big or as as fulfilling as what I
tasted during the wireless journey I
wanted it to be really societal and
transformative and then I wanted to make
sure that when it happened I I had a
workl feeling like an excitement and um
truth be told uh when I heard about
zuk's uh my first
reaction was yeah but
no sounds complicated why is
that well first of all I mean you know
you can these days when they tell you
about a company you go do some research
and you know there were some interesting
things there were some interesting
things okay you know one co-founder
wasn't there anymore and so you know
that only happens when things are
complicated let's put it that way the
second thing was uh I was like this is
going to take a lot of time and
capital and then the third thing was uh
I wasn't
sure that there's a lot of tech for tech
here there's a lot of chasing the
valuation and chasing the headlines and
hoping you're going to be the next you
know the few names and I I wanted to do
something really meaningful and I I I
didn't know for sure if that company was
embarking on that complicated that
expensive and that critical of a
technology and product I wanted to make
people make sure people were serious
about it and I didn't know because I had
not met the people and so again back to
Marshall he was like well it taks all
the boxes it's just there are some
things you're not sure about why don't
we go talk to
them so talked to a few board members
and then uh met Jesse levenson uh and I
met him uh actually we walked around uh
zuk's that day so I got to see the
energy and people were working on the
vehicle and everything and within about
15 20 minutes I was like wow I I I I I
got the feeling and the tingle and I was
like let's go let's do this
yeah joining well you talked a little
bit about some of the Dynamics there
with the co-founders I want to touch on
that a little bit more joining zuk's as
the first CEO after co-founder you did
navigate what many would consider a
challenging transition for GSB students
in the audience who may step into
leadership roles at existing companies
how did you establish your place and set
expectations after at
zuk's well first in my mind you do that
before you join the company and so uh
once I started uh thinking um yeah zuk
is it probably um I spent a lot of time
with Jesse we had dinner lunch we talked
I must have I I I must have I've sent
him I don't know hundreds of well maybe
tens of emails uh anytime I had a
question we texted um and I really
wanted to understand what this person
was made of uh what their value system
is uh why they were in it uh why they
thought that I was a fit but from in
their own words but I also wanted to
understand what's important to them and
could I bring that to the table for them
and so we spent a lot of time and I was
like you outside of my husband and kids
this is the person I'm going to spend
the most time with yeah and so we talked
about life we talked about technology we
talked about the challenges ahead and we
talked about also okay it's we're dating
right now work dating but you know what
happens when we don't agree and what
happens when um we annoy each other and
so we covered a lot of ground uh and I
don't know it uh it made a lot of sense
so my first piece of advice is only take
the role is if you're really interested
in it startups are
hard the idea is rarely the problem
execution is sometimes the problem
determination you just literally have to
have irrational belief and be determined
that it's going to work
out and when it's tough you find a way
you make a way you back up the boat you
reassess you pivot and so if you don't
have that irrational belief and pull
don't do it but if you do now in the
conversation understand what type of
founder you're dealing with ask some of
these questions that I've just gone
through and ask yourself very very
honestly can you can you provide that
and will you have the generosity to does
that make sense that makes sense and if
you do that then you can do anything
anything if anything now Jesse and I
have the opposite problem which is like
people are oh you know you guys agree
all the time or oh you know it's imp
it's intimidating because it's
impossible to convince you of you know
but once the two of you start going and
I'm like yeah but that wasn't built
overnight that was built over a certain
period of time and working together
having generosity because look at it
from my standpoint it is probably not
wise to walk into zuk's and alienate the
person who knows the most about it
because they are pting over in the
corner because some lady showed up and
she's like hi I'm the boss now that
doesn't work right you have to create
that partnership you have to create that
give and get and and we have codes like
he if he says I don't feel strongly or
if one of us says I don't feel strongly
why pick a fight you know just pick one
way over the other or if one says I feel
strongly we talk about it there are
times I think we've talked I mean for
hours and hours and I think genuinely
we've annoyed each other maybe a couple
times in five years mm wow that's pretty
impressive just a couple of times in
five years well I know you talked about
determination and that is a theme that
definitely came up after you spent you
know that those first few months really
establishing that
partnership in your first year as CEO
you helped sell the company to Amazon
for $1.3
billion how did you approach this major
deal and why was Amazon the right fit
for zukes so first of all I'm neither
confirmed ing not denying $1.3 billion
okay just so so we're clear not it good
thank you uh second uh there was a bunch
there were a bunch of us uh I mean I
played a role but others did too look we
are at zuk's you know I don't want to
turn this into a marketing pitch because
it isn't it we we're in love with what
we do yeah we are committed to what we
do uh we are committed to each other in
getting it done it's one of these
products where um it's not about which
team got an A it's about collectively
making sure that no teams gets an F
because it's a vertically integrated
safely safety critical product where
you're always as good as your last
release it's also from the ground up so
you have a A diversity of skills
background one day you're talking to you
know somebody about brakes and
powertrain and battery and the next day
you're talking to somebody about you
know perception and planning and control
and Ai and yeah start counting how many
times I say AI
I'll try to keep it low and so um at the
end of the day it's it's really about
we're just in love with what we do so
we're committed to getting to Market we
don't want to be a demo we we we we
really dream of this world and I might
not be there at that time uh but this is
a legacy role where we dream of this day
when a service that people already like
today it's just we will provide it in a
a better way for the
customer uh for Society for cities we
dream of that day where it's just going
to be ubiquitous where the term muber
mommy Uber will no longer
exist okay so now in doing that it also
takes a lot of capital it's safety
critical so schedules are very they're
not very deterministic because the
trigger to loue or to do anything is
rooted on not just the functionality but
on the safety case and proving it out
and so at the end of the day when when
we looked at all this we said it'd be
good to have a great partner with us
it'd be good to focus just on doing that
as opposed to always having this
pressure of you know I I call it like
investors don't pay for
plumbing no they don't pay for like you
know making sure you have the right
processes the right methodologies they
they only pay for outputs and if you're
in a situation where you have to Tin up
on a yearly basis big amounts of money
yet you're building something that
really Builds on each other there can be
a conflict and we could see that uh some
of our fellow Travelers had you know
great parents and we were like well why
not us and then Amazon Amazon it's a
great company uh it's uh it's
patient uh it's
Innovative um um they obviously from a
growth standpoint we're we're an
interesting bet I think that's what Andy
called us publicly and it's also obvious
that uh once we're successful the
technology we're bringing to Bear might
be useful in other areas and so it's
been a great great great great
partnership it's been three years now I
would give it a 8.5 n out of 10 which
you know coming out of aish evans's
mouth that's pretty good that's pretty
good yeah well you know I mean there's
always a tax right I mean if anybody
sells you that there's a perfect Journey
where everybody's perfect and the plan
is perfect please don't go there or go
there and change it one of the two and
so that's uh that's how we made the
decision and it was during the pandemic
and so uh there was a lot of clarity
during the pandemic right yes okay I
want to level set a little bit for the
for the audience so zuk's at the time
was about fewer than 1,000 people Amazon
in total has 1.5 million or so MH has
the acquisition changed the culture at
zuk and are there ways that you've had
to adapt as a leader under the new
partnership um no the what I respect and
love about Amazon is that uh um it's
it's a very direct and consequential
culture and they're like look uh we are
buying this because we like the
technology and the approach you guys are
the experts and so we're going to let
you do your thing now we're going to
agree on you know governance we're going
to agree on U sort of uh your tenure
plan and your execution and your markers
and uh but they don't really they they
have lots of things to do they don't
really come in they ask good questions
so no it hasn't changed the culture at
all we had actually a little bit of a
I'm I'm very big on culture uh again
safety critical you have to have a great
culture where anybody can uh can say hey
there's a problem here and so one of the
things we we had to do was more internal
to zuk hey hey hang on a second we're
keeping our mentality our mindset our
our Focus we're not like oh we just
inherited some rich parents we had to
make sure that we made a collective PCT
with it with each other that we were
going to be very disciplined continue as
if we were private uh and fight for for
for rigor and for discipline and so from
that standpoint uh there was a a change
but it wasn't really a change it was
more like let's continue the way we are
then as a leader well I had to dust off
uh my uh uh Intel leadership skills
right so uh uh but that's okay uh uh
it's been great the the Amazon is again
very consequential so I didn't have to
do I mean I think it's good that I knew
Both Worlds okay because I'm a good
bridge between Both Worlds but in
general there wasn't anything major I
have to go to Seattle more okay okay yes
yeah but there's
S4 well I want to transition and talk a
little bit from transition from culture
and the acquisition and talk a little
bit more about the industry more broadly
so zuk is still a relatively new company
where does it fit in the autonomous
vehicle landscape and what makes it
different so well new you know we're 9
years old relatively relatively I see
okay I'll I'll take it then um we we had
a big year uh we um uh for those who are
not familiar it's uh it's not a car uh
it's a big robot it's really a computer
on
Wheels uh and uh it's uh it looks a
little bit like um uh a little moving
living room in terms of the carriage
sitting in terms of sliding doors to get
in it's really optimized around Riders
and so um building that uh testing it
and then getting it on public roads uh
was a big deal for us this year that was
one of our big big goals um um and uh if
uh you you know move around or come
visit us uh you see it moving around
some of the some days it's early morning
I'm getting to work and I'm thinking
about okay the day what do I need to
think about and whatever so I'm not
really thinking about the vehicle or the
robot or the robo taxi and I'll look up
and see it whis by me and I'm like oh
she's so
cute very cute oh uh By Design because
we want you to feel an attraction as a
customer we want you to be transported
by this vehicle we want you to think do
I drive no I'm going to take a zook yeah
and so uh relative to the industry um
there are a few of us um it's a small
circle we talk to each other we
understand each other we have different
approaches obviously for us we started
by think we started thinking what is the
best way to
deliver the best experience or at least
the better experience than people have
today getting in a strangers car we all
do it but you know that's that's
different and we
designed the vehicle and its experience
relative to that then we said okay AI is
going to do the driving via sensors and
comput what is needed how do you
architect it and we said it needs to be
safe on all vectors in how it drives in
terms of the passenger in terms of the
the the safety ratings in terms of the
crash performance in terms of all these
elements so we are very vertically
integrated and optimized a lot of people
think oh my gosh they're doing the app
and they're doing the service and and
they are doing the vehicle and or the
robot and they are doing the AI stack
it's not we're doing everything we are
at the intersection of everything that
matters and we take that and apply it to
that now uh we have fellow Travelers
again and some are doing very well uh
some are experiencing uh challenges uh
right now but what we're committed to is
that uh this is going to happen it will
take a little bit more time probably
than people would like but it's always
like that with a big disruptive
technology MH autonomous vehicles have
been a topic of conversation for many
years but they're still not as common as
we'd like on our roads help us
understand why that is and what some of
the major obstacles are
so um how many of you have heard of the
oh there are 43,000 fatalities in the US
due to car
crashes yeah so a good I would say a
good 75% how many of you have also heard
that collectively in the United States
we human drivers drive a 100 million
miles per single
fatality
you okay yes don't worry you'll get your
a we know you did your research right
and there in and there in lies the
problem uh the part about the 43,000
meaning respecting the rules not being
drunk uh not being sleepy not being
distracted that part computerss and AI
of they're just good at that the part
about 100 million miles I mean think
about it for those of you who have
engineering backgrounds right you cannot
test through 100 million miles right you
have to have a quantifiable safety case
based and rooted in math in PRI and
statistics in falsies the system
engineering discipline of Aviation and
you're only as good as your last
software release second of all there are
there's there are so many like in
scenarios and a tail end of it so yes we
use simulation but there's always
potentially some scenario that do you
know it's almost like it's more
important to know not just what you know
how to handle but do you know what you
don't know how to handle and how you
would handle it and that is what makes
it extremely hard and second element is
yes we probably over time will have more
uh regulation I mean there's a reason
FAA exists right we all get on planes
because in the FAA we trust at the end
of the day um but at the end of the day
when you look
at Trust of consumers consumers are not
going to adopt these as a mode of
transportation if they don't trust the
safety and not just because the company
said so but because there are other
environmental elements that
almost implicitly say it is so and
that's why it's hard I want to talk
about safety in more detail as you know
Cruz one of zuk's competitors has
recently faced significant safety issues
which has led to the suspension of their
operations and a recall in their
vehicles in light of these industry
challenges how is zuk's really working
to ensure the safety and reliability of
its own autonomous vehicles so I mean I
I hope you'll respect that I won't
comment on Cruz uh I wish them the best
um it's a very small circle we all know
each other or somebody who knows each
other and uh as they've publicly St
stated I am sure they are internally in
there figuring things out and preparing
to reset and we wish them the absolute
best most of the time I call them again
fellow Travelers as far as safety at zuk
it's foundational and it's in everything
we do uh a lot of people uh we had
actually uh maybe about a year ago um a
company come in and uh who they sort of
looking at our safety and they ask me um
how come you don't have a single owner
of you know single what do they call it
like neck to choke or whatever the
expression throat to choke or whatever
for for safety I'm like I don't want
that I don't want safety to be in the
hands of a single person at zuk I want
safety to be in the hands of all of us I
want people to have a multitude of
channels whatever is available to them
whatever is most comfortable to them so
that they can report or discuss or ask
questions about safety second at zuk we
will not put a robot on the road unless
our very
rigorous strictly Quantified and
quantifiable safety case gives us the
metric via road driving via simulation
via analysis VI F three both by the way
what I call Direct simulation but also
scenario based and adversarial
simulation and so we're very rigorous
around that and we have five different
Executives that have to sign off before
Jesse and I even sign off and any single
one of those say no go we don't go then
there's what I call the sort of more
subtle stuff if you tell people safety
is really important report everything
and the first time somebody reports
something that's going to delay your
Milestone you're like
you think people will report no they
won't that's not the way people are
wired and so we trying to be we try and
be very open around that and we
encourage and you know we're on public
roads sometimes a couple things have
happened where we're like hey somebody
said we need to pause and analyze what
happened replay simulation look at the
scenario look at the code look at the
results and so that's that's really it
permeates through everything we do now
in addition there is uh all of the
safety that we've um because again we
think about the rider we think about the
vehicle or the robot uh our airbag
system uh so we have over 100 uh safety
innovations that are specifically for
this Robo taxi because we know what's
what's at stake uh the amount of
redundancy we've thought about uh I a
lot of people say you have a lot of
sensors yeah we do yeah because we want
to give ourselves all the chances on
pering the environment around us and the
interactions and also having redundancy
around that but also being fail
operational and fail safe and so
hopefully I'm giving you a glimpse it's
it's really at the foundation of
everything we do yeah I can tell and and
I told you earlier this week I actually
had the opportunity to sit in a rot taxi
and I felt quite safe if I may say so
myself felt like a little cocoon yes
just snug right on yeah well I want to
transition and talk a little bit about
the future um one of the big concerns
with the autonomous vehicle industry is
job security so as you know nearly 5
million people drive for Uber lft door
Dash some other delivery service none
the less Amazon drivers how is zuk's
thinking about the potential impacts on
society as it relates to job
displacement okay so I'm going to take
it again back to uh uh telecommunication
right um I hope some of you know that uh
it wasn't that long ago that to make a
phone call there needed to be a human
that plugged in something
and then another human reive something
and then finally click you could talk
right uh and then lots of generations of
that so uh here we are today there's no
human in all of your communication
correct okay good now I think there will
be a
transition I'm not going to shy away
from that but uh when you when you study
history every time there's been a big
disruption like this there's a period of
transition but on the other side of that
transition is also a new ecosystem where
new jobs are created and where societies
move up we expect that to happen here
too this robot Believe It or Not does
not know how it to charge
itself does not know how to clean
itself does not know how to do a lot of
things that it will you need humans to
help basically accomplish those things
there will also be an ecosystem you can
imagine like when when you look we take
a lot of things for granted relative to
uh the auton autonom mobile ecosystem
today gas stations lots of different
things all that will also happen Okay so
I want to be honest there will be a
transition but in the end we think that
there will be benefit and new jobs will
be created and the thing with autonomous
vehicles uh and the industry at large is
the transitions actually is much slower
than everybody anticipated and so our
Our Hope and I wish is that that
transition also is proportional and goes
at the same time and then flips at some
point okay great well I have so many
more questions for you but I want to
save time for our audience to ask
questions as well before I do I have one
final question from me which is
something we're asking all of our
speakers in line with our theme Aisha as
the CEO of zukes if there's one change
that you could make to redefine tomorrow
what would it
be it's um it's not realistic but I'm I
it's still you ask you know if
yes I wish we could take a pause and
clean up the internet before we embark
on this wave of AI we're we're on that's
irreversible I know that's probably not
possible or maybe it is I don't know but
I wish we could do just a quick sweep
and clean
up before we let let things loose
interesting is there what what are some
of your
concerns because I don't want to get in
trouble I will use a different
transition you know when we went from um
sort of the physical analog world to the
digital world right uh you know you used
to go have to go to the library and read
books and all the the data the beginning
of the data set was a lot
cleaner the megaphones were a lot
smaller
and right now we've uh in that
transition plus with other technologies
that have come in uh we have a lot of
clutter out there that is borderline
dangerous um and again I'm not talking
about centure here I'm for all opinions
and Views that's you know I'm we were
talking in the Green Room about Plato
and Socrates they are the foundation for
me uh when I sometimes get confused I
reread the Republic just to kind of
ground me and uh but we we we we have a
lot of mess out there that uh uh to the
uneducated or to the unaware there's a
potential for trouble and unfortunately
uh we're not going to clean it up uh but
at some point we will have to pause in
some way and or form and clean it up
again MH uh because uh over the over our
history as a human species eventually at
inflection points we do do the right
thing which is why we've survived this
long but I I wish we could just pause
just just just a couple weeks clean some
things up yeah well thank you for that
answer we'll now open it up to questions
for our audience I just wanted to pick
your brains on autonomous vehicles and
if you think do you think this is a
solution to a US problem or do you see
this also transferring to Europe where
cities are much more connected with
public transportation or to Africa and
Emerging Markets where the roads look
very different than the US and in terms
of also its affordability there
um I mean I of course I'm going to say I
don't think that uh it's a solution in a
search of a problem because I value my
time so I'm sure you expected that
answer look um I I think that it depends
on where you are the one thing I know is
that in general
um it's a very inefficient system
today uh it's not a very connected
system today I I mean transportation
and uh it hasn't really seen uh a
revolution or a transformation for a
while and at scale meaning as more
people come up uh uh societal levels in
terms of uh buying power uh there just
aren't enough roads we're going to fry
this planet all of the things that you
you hear so I I think that it's
inevitable but it will look different in
different places and so you know
Americans love their
cars so if we get to a point over a few
decades no it's part of the fabric of
this country let's face it so if we get
to a certain point over the next few
decades where we go from 2.x Cars to 1.x
car that's that's good more good things
will happen from that whereas uh uh
countries like for example uh like China
China's already very organized a lot of
people don't realize for example in
Beijing you have rings and your driver's
license doesn't allow you necessarily to
go through all rings so you can see that
there's already thinking around how do
you teer Transportation uh in in Africa
well there's opportunity for actually
Green Fields for autonomous only Lanes
so I I think that it will look different
in different places but in all cases it
will connect with the the current
transportation system and be one of the
modalities it's just in here it'll be
more like free form uh whereas in some
countries it'll be Green Field was
whereas in some countries it'll be
mandated hi Aisha thank you my name is
Rob first that shirt is amazing I just
have to say that it's very incredible
thank you yes I'm a first year in the
School of Business and education and you
mentioned that uh with the wave of
digitization and autom and automation
that there will be new jobs created but
I'm I'm curious your thoughts on job
dislocation as that transition is
happening and what role does zukes or
any other companies play in forwarding
drivers who lose their jobs and
reskilling into more uh different
different different uh opportunities in
that regard yeah so um uh thank you and
thank you for that compliment I much
appreciate
it I don't look like this every day
normally it's a hoodie and jeans and
boots uh so um look we're already
creating a lot of jobs I mean uh zuk's
uh we have all kinds of jobs I mean like
I said one day you're talking to the AI
like Guru the other day you're talking
to okay what's happening with the brake
systems and and what have you uh we also
do a lot of testing uh L3 we call it
level three testing but basically we're
driving in autonomy but there's a safety
driver uh behind the wheel we we we
through some agencies uh we bring that
in a lot uh we have dreams of uh oh we
have um also uh all of the support
system now now that we're trying
starting to head towards
commercialization we have to have Depots
we have to have uh uh telegu guidance
systems and so we consider it our
responsibility those are not jobs that
necessarily exist today per se as a
clear profile but we have training uh we
have C sort of our own internal
certification so we we are already doing
that I don't want to take too much
credit because we need to be able to do
this at scale but that movement is
already
happening so my name is py I am a je
degree electrical engineering and MBA
student here at Stanford final year
let's
go um so my question is there've been a
couple of failures within the autonomous
vehicle space right and like billions
and billion dollars kind of lost so what
is it that zuk is doing so well compared
to some of the other ones and I guess
what what do you think are some of the
things they didn't do so well U that
you're kind of close correcting for
you're not going to get me to comment on
others that's just not what I do because
I don't like it when people comment on
us so I don't comment on AOS what I can
tell you uh zuk is very focused on is uh
it's actually a thing at zuk we use a
lot of uh sort of analogies and common
language and uh I promise you that if
you meet somebody from zuk and you ask
them what is tiny small medium large
scale rinse and repeat they will tell
you oh yeah that's something we use
because we really try and be slow
careful measured we think this is a long
game uh by now you know you've heard all
my Spiel around history and philosophy
and it sometimes I now I'm I'm going to
go on my Soap Box sometimes I I I have
to remind myself that okay we're special
but we're not so special okay this world
I mean folks have been doing incredible
things for society Humanity advancement
you know for a while if you could wake
up somebody who passed away 2,000 years
ago and dropped them in the middle here
right now they they wouldn't even I mean
they they'd be like we probably would
have to take them to a psychiatric
hospital cuz they'd be like whoa so I
trust Humanity I I I am optimistic uh
big things though Aviation took a while
lots of billions of dollars uh even the
the the internal the the the current
passenger automobile took a while I mean
go look at some of the Articles uh about
New York and the infrastructure of New
York and the horses and the carriage and
the jobs and the stables at the end of
the day you have to be measured you you
do have to have irrational belief
otherwise you don't start sometimes at
zooks I run into somebody who's been
there for a long time and be like Oh I'm
really sorry that we didn't do XYZ I'm
like well if you had thought of doing
XYZ you wouldn't have started zooks or
you wouldn't have been that early
because there are phases and I think
what zuk is doing really well is slowing
down understanding the weight of what
we're doing and being very measured
along the way knowing that this is a
long game and still very
hi I'm Tiffany I'm part of the
Trailblazer cohort of the leads program
um thank you for your thoughts on the AI
um it's really hit home on um I think
that Pandora's Box might have been
already open um my question is on um you
mentioned you were only irritated with
your partner a few times um I'm
wondering as someone coming up in the
ranks how much should you allow
irritation or one-sided generosity
um before you move to something
else she's so elegant in the way she
asked her question she
is um look I I I first of all I I I want
to I want to make sure uh We've
irritated each other so just so we're
clear
um yes I get mad I think that's what
you're asking I get I get annoyed I get
uh I I'm on a journey uh I try very hard
uh I also know my triggers everybody at
zuk's who interacts with me will tell
you that uh Friday 5:00 p.m. is not the
best time uh to be having a difficult
meeting with me or if you're going to
have it then I I have to really prepare
myself because by that time I'm
exhausted uh and I'm also thinking about
okay you know it's the weekend and you
know your kids they would I mean now
they're teenagers they don't care but
there's that middle period where they're
like oh that's kind of interesting how
you only have energy for work and so
literally I think about Friday as okay
glass of wine that part is good the part
that's not good it's like showtime at
home on Saturday um but in general I try
really hard uh to treat people how uh
they how I want to be treated an extra
point if I understand how they want to
be treated uh uh I have a rule of three
uh after three uh come on it's not
working uh I try and encourage with
saying I'm not afraid of mistakes I'm
I'm more but let's look for new mistakes
which is code for old mistake learning
what do we do about it but yeah
occasionally I will lose it if I lost it
in a uh in a way that I am not I'm I'm
really mad at myself for and I usually
know because my best performance review
is every essentially every night if I
can't sleep uh I'll go apologize there's
somebody at zuk's who uh very early on
uh caught me in a in a moment I was
tired I was stressed and W I was not
proud out of how uh how I acted I went
and found that person uh you can imagine
when they saw me coming they were like
oh
gosh uh but I I said look I'm really
sorry uh I um I lost it um I will try to
do better I can't promise promise
Perfection uh but there are also times
where people are like wow you are
ruthless and I'm like yeah it was needed
I felt like unless I did that we were
not going to have the conversation oops
sorry the
conversation we needed to have what I
can promise you though is I'm
loving because I I do think uh that's
another thing uh from Marshall and Alan
malali in particular to do what we do we
we we have to love what we do but we
also have to love each other so it's a
loving environment and the same way if
you could talk to my kids they would
tell you uh some things that I'm not
proud of I'm not going to sit here and
tell you that I'm perfect I go on a
journey of Discovery and a journey of uh
continuous
Improvement awesome Aisha it's view from
the top tradition that we end every
single interview with the series of
Rapid Fire questions okay so I'm GNA
make a statement and then you will fill
in the blank with the first thing that
comes to mind and we'll go really
quickly okay the dish I was best known
for when I owned a restaurant was oh
easy Chu Jen my number one role model in
the field of science and Innovation is
Mary cury my favorite way to spend time
outside of work be a
bum my dream robo ta
co-passenger Nelson
Mandela and one piece of advice I wish I
knew earlier in my career take a Chell
pill it's going to be
okay Aisha thank you so much for joining
us at you from the top thank
[Music]
you
that